I have this bodyguard incorporated yeah
I'd like to hire Liam Neeson for a 24/7
shift the gray stars Liam Neeson it's
about a team of Alaskan drillers and
Liam Neeson is the guy who they hired to
kill any wolves who may attack them at
any point in time because apparently
wolves in Alaska attacked people all the
time now when they're all in a plane
going somewhere their plane actually
crashes and they get stranded in this
extremely remote area of Alaska where
there's nothing but ice trees and wolves
Liam Neeson being the wolf master that
he is is the guy who decides to try to
help all these guys try to survive this
wilderness area survive being attacked
by the wolves and find some form of
civilization Liam Neeson is kind of like
his character in taken except with
wolves like he knew everything about
wolves he had a very special set of
skills involving wolves he knew
everything about surviving in the
wilderness when Liam Neeson is just
awesome I really like Liam Neeson he is
by far the best part of this Phil miss
performance is very good it was a
believable role in regards to his
physicality and in regards to his
emotion that he put into his character
the gray was a solid thriller it's
directed by joe carnahan the guy who
made a team which you know 18 was
alright and it was just a kind of fun
little movie the main antagonist of this
movie is a group of wolves who are
picking off men one by one and it's a
little bit hard to believe if you know
anything about wolves generally wolves
don't really attack people that much
that film makes it convincing though
because it makes it seem as if the men
are encroaching upon the Wolves
territory and that's what's got them all
riled up and everything and that that
seems like it could happen and it
probably does happen if you ever seen it
would be called the edge with Alec
Baldwin and Anthony Hopkins it was
basically like that except it was in an
area that was freezing and instead of
bears it was wolves plus is about this
movie are Liam Neeson's performance and
the use of location I really honestly
felt freezing during this movie I mean I
really felt like I was there the wolves
as villains worked the best when they
were off-screen when you would see their
glowing eyes in the distance or see
their breath just forming in the
distance
oh boy there's a wolf right there for me
that was when the wolves are most
frightening when it was building up to
them possibly being there when they were
actually there or when they attacked
someone it didn't really look very
realistic lots of shaky-cam couldn't
really tell what was going on for the
most part I bought them as villains now
there's a major problem I have with this
movie and you may have noticed by now
that I'm not actually using the trailer
in this review and that's because the
trailer of this movie gives away not
only the ending of the film but it
actually makes you think that something
happens that doesn't so if you haven't
watched the trailer please avoid it
because it kind of ruined the ending of
the movie for me not just because I knew
it was going to happen but because I was
expecting something to happen that
didn't and it was a little bit
disappointing it's not really the film's
fault though at first I was mad at the
movie but then I realized it's really
the trailers fault so I can't really
fault the movie for that some of the
problems I had with the gray were I
found some of the side characters to be
really uninteresting Liam Neeson's
character I was very much invested in
but for the most part I found the other
man in the group pretty boring the side
characters were a little bit cliched and
so when some of those characters were
threatened I didn't feel very much
invested in them getting hurt I didn't
really care so much I was just really
with Liam Neeson the whole time the gray
is kind of a bleak thriller it's not
where those movies are gonna leave and
be like I'm just gonna go look at
rainbows all day it is whatever a good
ride and it's very intense I'm gonna
give the gray Abbey
I'd like to know what's your favorite
Liam Neeson movie I actually don't know
what mine is I'm not very good at
choosing those kind of things if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel on get stuck my nice
[Music]